parlons de ce maire un qui a annoncé sa
démission il est maire de Saint-Brevin
Yannick Morèze il a démissionné après
que son domicile a été incendié et le
maire qui dans un courrier au préfet
dénonce un manque de soutien de l'État
cette question toute simple de quoi
est-ce le symptôme alors tout d'abord il
faut apporter sa solidarité envers le
maire de Saint-Brévin
Loire-Atlantique on n'est pas dans
l'Oise mais dans l'Oise j'ai même sujet
ou des mammaires a été menacée et a
appelé à l'aide et l'État n'est pas
intervenu suffisamment tôt donc il a
finalement craqué démissionné alors
qu'il prenait son métier à coeur et là
en l'occurrence à Saint-Brevin c'est le
déplacement pragmatique d'un centre
d'accueil de demandeurs a voulu déplacer
il veut déplacer alors là c'est
absolument incroyable le déchaînement de
violence cette violence c'est ça qui est
ça c'est symptomatique de la violence
aujourd'hui de l'expression politique la
démocratie est la plus lieu le choix
d'un maire n'est plus respecté on
commence par le menacer physiquement on
se reprend assez bien on peut le brûler
vif vous savez c'est le cas partout
moi-même comme l'ensemble des sénateurs
de l'Oise à une époque reçu une
cartouche à notre domicile et nous avons
reçu une une remarque de la procureur
que la sens ensuite la faire ah donc on
est tous aujourd'hui sous ce phénomène
de violence des comptes pas et bien on
est on se sent autorisé à menacer et à
s'en prendre c'est pas de la menace ça a
brûlé chez lui et la menace essayer là
c'est pas la première fois sur votre
plateau où j'interviens sur ce sujet
l'exécutif justement en fait-il assez on
voit que les sénateurs tirent la semaine
d'alarme avec une proposition de loi de
Madame Delattre également la négation
aux collectivités locales est-ce que
l'exécutif en fait assez on sait le
maire qui a parlé d'un manque de soutien
de l'État dans son courrier dans ce
courrier et ça avait été évoqué par ma
collègue sénatrice de Loire-Atlantique
Laurence Garnier c'est fait plusieurs
fois le ministre dit c'est de la
violence intolérable il y a pas de
violence tolérable déjà la violence est
intolérable mais derrière il se passe
rien on ne met pas les moyens et la
justice n'est pas assez sévère il y a un
moment il faut quand même interroger le
garde des sceaux là-dessus car c'est la
politique pénale qui n'est pas assez
forte là dessus
[Musique]